we are told that a baker uses eight cups
of flour to make one batch of muffins
for his bakery
complete the table for the given ratio
so they're saying that for every batch
he needs eight cups of flour or he needs
eight cups of flour for every batch
sofini had two batches how many cups of
flour would that be pause the video and
try to figure it out
well if he has twice as many batches
he's going to have twice the number of
cups of flour so instead of 8 it would
be 16 cups of flour and if you had 3
times the number of batches it would be
3 times the number of cups of flour so
instead of 8 it would be 8 times 3 or
24.
now down here they say plot the ordered
pairs x comma y from the table on the
following graph so we want to graph one
batch eight cups two batches 16 cups
three batches 24 cups so let's do that
so let's see if you can okay so
right here this i'm assuming on the
horizontal axis that is our batches and
then our vertical axis is cups of flour
so for every batch we need eight cups of
flour so one batch this is eight right
over here five six seven eight
and then for two batches we're going to
need 16 cups of flour so that puts us
right over there that's 16. and then for
three batches we are going to need 24
cups of flour and that actually goes
slightly off of our screen here let me
scroll up a little bit
so for three batches
we are going to have to bring that to
24 which is right here and i can see the
25 right above that and what you'll see
because the ratio between our batches
and our cups of flour are constant that
all of these points you could connect
them all with one straight line because
we have a fixed ratio every time we move
one to the right we're gonna move eight
up every time we add another batch we're
gonna have eight more cups of flour
every time we add a batch eight more
cups of flour
let's do another example
here we're told drew earns money washing
cars for his neighbors on the weekends
drew charges a set rate for each car he
washes the points on the following
coordinate plane show how much drew
charges for two five and eight cars so
let's see what's going on over here
so when he washes two cars he looks like
he charges fifteen dollars when he
washes five cars it looks like he's
charging
well it looks like someplace between 35
and 40 dollars and he charges eight cars
it looks like he's charging sixty
dollars
so one way to think about it is the
ratio between the number of cars he's
washing and the dollars it stays at two
to fifteen notice two cars for every
fifteen dollars i guess i could say
fifteen dollars for every two cars and
so when you go to eight cars your
multiplying by four the number of cars
and you're also multiplying by four the
number of dollars and so once again
since we have a fixed ratio here all
three of these points sit on the same
line but then they ask us down here they
say how much does drew charge for four
cars
well if it's fifteen dollars for two
well then four cars would be twice as
much so it would be thirty dollars for
four cars
we have the same ratio
let's do one more example
here we're told mckenna earns money each
time she shovels snow for her neighbors
as she should mckenna plots points on
the coordinate plane below to show how
much she earns for different numbers of
times she shovels snow
all right
so let's see when she shovels snow three
times looks like she gets see halfway
between 16 and 20. looks like she gets
four times look it's 24
so it looks like the ratio is staying
constant at 3
to 18. the ratio of 3 to 18 is the same
thing as
or
one way to think about it is 18 for
every three times she shovels snow
that'd be equivalent six dollars for
every time she shovels snow
so let's go down here to see what
they're asking us
they say which of the following ordered
pairs could mckenna add to the graph
so this would be one time shoveling snow
would she get ten dollars for it
so does she get ten dollars for every
time she shovels snow no that wouldn't
be consistent with the data here
she got eighteen dollars for shoveling
snow three times so that looks like
she's getting six dollars for every time
she shovels snow
so
i would rule out
choice a
choice b shoveling snow twice she gets
12 well that makes sense if she gets six
dollars every time she shovels snow if
the ratio of shoveling of the times to
the dollars is three to eighteen or one
to six that would be equivalent to two
to twelve and we would pick that choice